[Applause]
john klein van damme is the only dude
that punches and flex
and you just looking at the muscle
you're not even looking at the move
hi my name is roy hall i'm a ufc fighter
my background is boxing kickboxing
kyokushin kai karate i know wrestling
and jiu-jitsu today we're gonna be
looking at mixed martial arts scenes in
movies and tvs and judging how real they
really are
he's throwing wild punches in the
beginning uh that's not really a smart
thing to do it leaves yourself open of
course the big guy would just capitalize
on it if i'm fighting someone that's
bigger than me movement is always going
to be important because you know for
them to chase me is going to take them
out of their element i recommend speed
on a person that's bigger than me any
type of straight technique down the pipe
because tray technique is always going
to be faster than round techniques body
shots will slow anybody down i think of
like a tree if i can chop them down with
the root then i can
finish them up up top
[Music]
with a guillotine that i know you can
either get them in here sometimes you
can get the person's neck underneath
here and just kind of use your hips it's
more of a hip position you add them
against the octagon so it's kind of hard
to get your hips up as someone's
pressing into you so it leaves you to
focus more on your hands so that looks
like a pretty realistic position
he's way too small to pull off that move
if someone has your neck here that's the
natural defense to kind of put your hand
over so naturally what you have to do is
go lower
to let the person roll underneath you
but it's hard to pick the person up
so the ground stuff looks pretty good a
little dramatic if he's turning around
to get that arm bar he's stepping around
like that that's too much space that
person could just rip their arm out
easily because in grappling you got to
stay tight very close you know there's
no none of this the thing that i noticed
a lot with mixed martial arts are
martial arts films they want that big
dramatic effect oh my god this is
happening
so that's a really good knee bar i mean
it's it's very deep he's got both legs
around he's got the person's leg close
to his head that's perfect it's dramatic
how he's putting his hand all the way
behind him that's just taking way too
much energy all you got to do is just
close your hand and
press your hip forward i would
definitely give this a 8 out of 10. i
think it's a great introduction towards
mma and a great story as well
i love this what he's doing right now
he's throwing that big right hand you
know and he's throwing that right hand
as well he slips under
that's one of the most coolest thing you
can do to grab someone to submit them
the person is choking you
with their arm on one side and you're
choking yourself
with your arm on one side right here so
if you get your arm here that's going to
close my arteries a little bit right and
then
no blood's going to go to the brain and
then i'm going to pass out
[Music]
that's totally accurate believe it or
not so he has a triangle leg lock and if
he has the arm he would just have to
kind of put it in the middle and press
his hips up and then you'll have like an
arm bar from there or if the person
turns into you you can transition to a
triangle but that is just great control
on the bottom if i can get my legs
around you like that then i'm
controlling you so a lot of people would
think you know if you're on top all the
time you have an advantage but you know
if i can use my legs to kind of pull you
in and control you push and pull right
if i'm pushing your arm here i'm pulling
you in under your armpit i'm pushing
your hips away i'm pulling you in my arm
and if i can get my legs around your
your waist here i can pull you in now
normally if someone's on top
you know you can strike but from here we
notice that he has his leg locked so now
i have one arm free i can't really do
much i can punch but the person on the
bottom is so far away
it's hard to hit them
this is textbook this is perfect if
anyone double legs you that's a natural
defense when someone grabs into your
legs
their head is going to be exposed now
granted when you do attack someone your
head should be up a little bit right and
that will make it a little harder but
even then you're still at risk so i
think what aaron did right away he just
locked in the guillotine and locked the
arms in and
you notice he locked his leg so now it's
even harder
for this guy to get out i mean this is
just perfect this this blows me away
this is 10 out of 10. i need to watch
i this love joncon vandam he's
definitely one of the guys if not the
guy to inspire me to kick because you
know i'm a kicker i knocked out guys
with spinning kicks i've learned other
cool kicks when i was 12
this was life round kicks one of my
favorite kicks that was pretty accurate
there's so many ways to do round kicks
if you're using the shin part of your
leg i would recommend it to either chop
the leg or you know hit him in the body
you can hit him in the face a little
harder use shin
i know this will never work nobody
should ever stand there and get kicked
with the same kick put your hands up
champ
and in a real fight i would definitely
be throwing a lot of low kicks as a
fighter i think more like a sniper i'm
the guy that waits and i look for that
perfect shot and i take it and i'm very
precise with it i contribute that to my
karate background because in karate we
had to
do tornado kicks and kick apples off
each other's heads so that's the type of
accuracy i had to have and
it kind of helped me throughout the rest
of my career
[Applause]
john klein van damme is the only dude
that punches and flex
and you just looking at the muscle
you're not even looking at the move
[Music]
[Applause]
that's where i got that kick from the
spinning hook kick uh
so many ways to do this kick what john
caught granddam just did right there is
an extension of his leg the further that
leg is out you know the more whip it's
gonna have
the stronger it's gonna be when i did
this kick to knock on my opponent on the
ultimate fighter i chambered my leg
so i spun but instead of extending it i
keep it intact
now that was because of the distance
because if he's close and i extend my
leg it's going to create that off
balance but in that spit of a second you
have to recognize that distance
i've been attempting that kick for years
still haven't gotten it you got to be
able to have a good split to do that
because what happened is when you extend
that leg you're using the other leg as
momentum to generate that power
not as realistic as it seemed because
it's so much energy to generate that
takes time to throw it and in that time
that person could have a defense
mechanism to go
i'm out of here
a lot of people don't train this area on
your leg you know it's that soft meat
your calf or even right below your ankle
it's like hitting with a bat so i
absolutely think leg kicks can win a
fight a great movie but it's not even
close time to give it a five sorry bro
still love you
as you see keanu is just evading and
that's one of the key things too
if someone's either sporadic or wild or
they're just throwing
it's good to kind of evade i was taught
a long time ago you could never fight
with rage
it just blinds you i've done it once in
my career it cost me and i can say that
plays a part in her just attack attack
attack there's the opening and he
blocked and defended it he grabbed the
hold of her
and gave her a judo throw it's genius
where someone keeps coming at you you
just use their momentum to throw them
yeah he's holding her back but she could
easily kick down throw some knees she
has her legs she wasn't really using
that
there's no pause in a real fight like
that i wouldn't be like you okay
you know you grab it you break but other
than that you know this this was just
phenomenal credit to keanu for doing all
of the stunts i would give it a 10 out
of 10.
there's some definitely some funny
moments
and as a dynamic striker one of the key
things i always look for
is how to perfect your technique and any
type of swinging motions like this is
usually an act of desperation or usually
i'm out of my element but we'll give it
to him because
dramatic effect dirty boxing is is more
than that it's not just punching and my
head is in your face i'm pushing you
it's uncomfortable it's just so
uncomfortable that you just want it to
stop you can't breathe you can't you
can't fight the way you want to fight
a very very genius uh move but if you
don't know how to get out of dirty
boxing then you fall victim
when homeboy fell no one just falls and
hold their legs you fall in mma longer
for more than two or three seconds that
is considered almost like a knockout i
have a hurt leg i'm not gonna show you
have a hurt leg i'm probably gonna kick
you with that hurt leg because the
moment my opponent recognized that he's
gonna exploit it granted i think what
this movie is is some underground
fighting so there's no rule apply but in
the real ufc
refs will see that
i love the jiu jitsu part on the floor i
love how they were just
back and forth because that's jiu jitsu
you're back you're forward one move
doesn't work you go to the next you
create chain moves from how they were
doing transitions to one move to the
next
shows that they have an idea of what's
going on
[Applause]
i think he's turning into a
uma pilata another common move it's so
hard to get out of you know it's one of
those moves where you're stuck and if
you don't really know how to get out of
it you can get hurt so for me i'm not
the best grappler in the world so i if i
get there i know how to get out and how
to maneuver myself to get back to my
strong suits what i would naturally try
to do is roll over if you notice the
person is going to stop you
automatically from rolling over and this
is just one of those positions where
it's a stalemate or it's like all right
who's going to impose the will to either
keep the person down or get out
i noticed he finished him at the end
i'm a strong person
if someone gets me into uma pilata
uh i don't see someone finishing me by
pressing down so hard it'll pull my
shoulder out i'm speaking for myself
i'll give this a 9 out of 10. the jiu
jitsu part here was really well done i
think
well i'm a big fan of michael jai white
i actually learned a kick from michael j
white he has what seven black belts so
that guy is actually legit so fighting
is like dancing
and it's about rhythm and right now
these guys are feeling each other's
rhythm each opponent has the counter for
that move he throws the technique he
blocks he hit back he counters he goes
back and it's just such a beautiful
piece to see like this i love to me this
is fighting this is getting in the zone
this won't last for long of course
because eventually someone will break
their rhythm whether it's fear whether
it's none of my stuff is working whether
it's this person bettering me or rather
than one of them getting clipped
[Music]
so what we're seeing right now is him
getting kind of a cross choke from
behind if his body was more attached to
michael jaiwide it would have been a
little stronger but his upper body is
more here so he's not latched on
properly so that helps michael jai white
gets out of that move a little easier
i love this whole my hand is up i kick
you low and i come back high i do it all
the time i don't do a back fist i'm all
do a jab
but this is michael jay white we're
talking about the faking is one of my
best traits to
use as i'm competing because it
interrupts i can create that opening and
if i create that opening then i can
exploit my opponent's weakness and once
i get you to react
then i can counter you properly
now this is what fighting should look
like almost almost i think that it's
uh similar to what i do with the
prettiness of the art of fighting the
dynamic way of striking but it is too
crisp and pretty there's not gonna be
too many standing in one spot there's
gonna be a lot more movement involved in
a real situation you know there's going
to be creating more openings more
grabbing the leg a little a little bit
of dirty boxing-ish to kind of create
that mixture of mixed martial arts
but it just looks too clean
the only way i can see something like
this working is because of the size
difference so putting that leg up that
opponent is feeling that weight
distribution and he just rolls but it
depends how you roll though and if you
roll backwards then you're rolling out
of the move so it's great for tv but i
wouldn't think a move like this will
really work in real life i would give
this a
9 out of 10. it's right there but it's
just not that it's not going to be that
pretty pretty much
oh my
this is so awkward now i gotta judge
myself way to go guys good job
yeah this was a cool uh scene man i got
to work one of the best but i think from
what i've learned from acting is that a
lot of times when you throw those
punches that way it's not just straight
to your face
depending on the camera angle it's gonna
look uh very good for tv but for the
untrained eye it's like wow but for the
rest of the og it's like what
stance is everything my stance
is another line of my defense you know
am i open enough where i can protect the
vault the four vulnerable areas such as
like my head
my neck my uh my solar plexus and my
groin and it makes a straight line that
45 degree angle most of the time you see
is protecting that right now we're kind
of feeling each other's rhythm
i love this part right here
well when i died but
oh
went out like a g
i mean you would have to be
very accurate to kick someone like that
because your kicks
are naturally
heavier than your arms plus my chin is a
little closer it's protecting that but
for this scene you know uh he didn't
kick me in the neck we actually took his
shoe
and someone put their fist
and put it at my neck
to make it look like a kick movies
playing movies all right i gotta i gotta
keep it real with myself um
again it goes back to that too clean
right if it's gonna be more scuffle like
the part where he grabbed me
and you know i was throwing some knees
it's gonna be more realistic like that
i'm gonna give myself a nine out of ten
using the environment in close quarters
like that just tossing each other
bouncing off of it i feel like this is a
real fight
when someone grabs your throat what a
lot of people don't realize that you're
stronger up here but as you go down
you're weaker so your wrist is naturally
weak so anything that involves me
putting pressure on this will alleviate
that pressure instinctively grabbing
something to hit that person i feel that
works
very well
using the plates using the uh curtains
using anything they can find so i rate
it 10 out of 10 because it's the closest
thing to a realistic fight on the street
or in a house
this
red flags you don't want to turn away of
course you turn away you're giving up
your back and you get real naked choke
just like we saw from the other cartoon
you want your legs wrapped around the
person so what i'm supposed to do is
push my hips back
bring my knee in and then try to wrap my
leg around the person but she has one
knee up which means it's hard for the
persons to cross over so that's the
natural defense side control position
looking to get to the mountain she's
there
so if you're in that position you never
want to step over remember what i said
about grappling being like this
if she steps over that creates space
and if anyone sees that on the bottom
they're going to push and get their leg
wrap
you want to slide your knee across their
stomach like this so my knee is going to
be crossing over
to get the mount position
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a lot easier for the person on top
to cover the person about a mouth the
person on top have more ways to move
their head than the person on the bottom
but what i think she's trying to do
is posture her up if i can push you away
a little bit
then i can create space but this is
risky because the moment i do that i set
myself up for an armbar
[Applause]
you get caught here at the finish you're
going night night this is
if not the hardest thing to get out of
what happened is when you put a weird
naked choke in think of it like a snake
you kind of stink around the neck if i
can get the crease of this part of my
arm
right in the middle here then i'm locked
in what i like to do when i put this
through i grab my own shoulder like this
now i'm locked in i think hallie did a
great job she snuck her arm in and she
got the other arm in like this and all
she had to do was squeeze and basically
you're cutting off the blood circulation
to the head you know i think she halle
berry did such a great job in
performing
this mma there's some small spatial
stuff but i don't think it's too much of
a big deal
i'm gonna probably give it like uh a
eight out of a ten
i think my favorite scene would be a
black widow if you take away the octagon
and you take away all the rules and
stuff a real scuffle would be like that
where they're using the entire
environment that is the closest thing
that i've seen to anything being real
from a missed martial arts perspective
so black widow
thanks for watching if you enjoy this
video i'm sure you'll like that one too